(upbeat pop music)
♪ I've got my high
school yearbook
♪ Flipping through,
and I'm looking back
♪ Thinkin' 'bout my friends
♪ Thinkin', hey,
wonder where they at
♪ Then I see Mr D,
my old math teacher
♪ I always wanted
to bang that guy
♪ Where is he now
♪ Does he still teach
♪ He was totally
the hottest teacher
♪ Can we hang out
♪ Is it allowed
♪ I feel like this is
weird, but I need to know
♪ When is it okay to have sex
♪ With my teacher
from high school
♪ Oo-Ooh
♪ When will I be old enough
♪ For this not to be weird
♪ I can feel it,
I know you feel it
♪ We had a lot of
weird moments in class
♪ When is it okay to have sex
♪ With my teacher
from high school
♪ Oo-Ooh
♪ For some weird reason
♪ I still had my
old teacher's number
♪ I said "hey", she said
♪ Where should we fuck
♪ It feels like it's wrong
♪ But it's been a long time
♪ Since I've
legally been a child
♪ I'm gonna do it
♪ But will she be the same
♪ No
♪ What's her first name
♪ Barb
♪ That is something
that I plan to look up
♪ Is she still thin
♪ No
♪ Does she have kids
♪ Can't
♪ I hope that this
lady doesn't have kids
♪ I have four dogs and
a lot of health problems
♪ When is it okay to have sex
♪ With my teacher
from high school
♪ Oo-Ooh
♪ When will society
not label
♪ This as weird
♪ I can feel it,
I know you feel it
♪ If you have a
family I understand
♪ I don't
♪ When is it okay to have sex
♪ With my teacher
from high school
♪ Ooh-Ooh
♪ We are teachers and we
know this is questionable
♪ I'm about to nail
a former student
♪ He looks the same as
he did in 10th grade
♪ But with facial hair
and a college education
♪ I'm so proud
♪ Let's get down
♪ When is it okay to have sex
♪ With my teacher
from high school
♪ Ooh-Ooh
♪ When will I be old enough
♪ For this not to be weird
♪ I can feel it,
I know you feel it
♪ One time you
straight up told me
♪ That I have a nice ass
♪ When is it okay to
have sex with my teacher
make love to my teacher
♪ When is it okay to have sex
♪ With my teacher
from high school
♪ Ooh-ooh
♪ Yeah ♪
- Wait, where are you going?
- I have a family.